[Musique]
sagbo cinquième mois si vous êtes le
maître de le mec de retard pour nos
stars non je pense à vide et au ghana
c'est notre style de vie mieux c'est
vrai ça vous manque pas ça vous étiez
coup le danton et concret qui fait rien
moi je sais que j'ai 26 ans mais c'était
qu'il mieux vous et sébastien folin
ouais voilà ça fait plaisir de vous
rencontrer en tout cas vraiment aux
lônes au delà ono [ __ ] c'est pas bon
ça me suis le pire des claustro mon ami
j'appelle les pompiers 10 avec un mot je
rigole pas donc jusque là aujourd'hui
c'est pire que la mort c'est pire que la
mauvaise journée
j'ai une gastro ouest reso raison tant
mieux
en plus là ça me stresse chante grave
que ça me stresse si je vous lâche
desquels je suis désolé j'ai un témoin
réseau indisponible
vous avez là c'est parti la première
année déjà parti je suis désolé et
d'appuyer comme un con bah ouais non
mais s'il faut bien que ça c'est
franchement décalé parce que jamais vous
lâcher une simple pièce mon ami oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] fait du bien aux sa glisse de
qui
assurément prochain gros coup j'ai donc
deux jambes la [ __ ] comment je suis
pas aulas c'est quoi ton toi [ __ ]
bernard quitte à bernard je suis pas
bien haha
[ __ ] attend attention c'est pas là il
y avait deux barrières l'une à côté de
l'autre je me tiens comme angers
wallonie
oh
je vais
[Applaudissements]
trois jours après le coupable mais
j'adore je vais te tuer le tri cap vers
la remontée
il va te tuer mais il est très diana qui
a failli vraiment s'énerver c'est
mokhtar ascenseur havok tard regardez il
est très très drôle et mokhtar en fait
ça s'est pas passé comme on aurait voulu
à la fin mais c'est très drôle quand
même
mokhtar le cac ascenseur sais pas
[Musique]
il m'arrive est une galère une fois je
me suis trouvé que j'ai passé ma soirée
dans le truck la personne qui vous savez
combien cela nous chercher ils sont
venus chez monsieur bloqué 18 tirs sont
venus à trois heures
merci du bassin pu enfin conseillé par
contre je rappelle que c'est moi où je
peux dire j'ai passé toute la soirée
[Musique]
il est
hu
pour les y avez-vous mois la police est
plus incertain
[Musique]
le tourniquet tranquille
en effet c'est bon c'est bon c'est mon
ciel tous [ __ ]
oh
[Musique]
genève une auto
les plus gros pigeon hill est un critère
est exceptionnel alors je dirais oui
mais en danger c'est apparemment il a pu
ouvrir vite la l'ascenseur mais mokhtar
tout ce que je te connais